oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
raconte moi quand tu es gay pays que
j'aime à dire j'aime beaucoup la place
mais en jours elles m'ont rendu très
malheureux accord allait recommencer
mais le corps baby schumi lui et
persique
merci merci je suis train touche bon
dieu je vais me surpasse c'est lui que
blanc je vois de la sla plus balle c'est
bien of honor un triomphe naturel fois
dans bercy
geagea a remises à des floralies la
mosquée j'ai subi un copain c'est le
garder ses fleurs et plus certainement
grand yaka il faut les ramasser ses six
à la ramasse et des fleurs rapporté les
moyens de se marrer au les jolis
bouquets mosca il faut mettre ces fleurs
des yeux madjer et marek rosiak je veux
les maîtres de la g de poti mais je
crains yaka et je vous l'avait offerte à
titus souvenez vous
ah oui oui oui je les donne et un têtu
ce moment mais ce qui est à titus est à
moi elle est ce si cela allait chercher
titus aller vite au forum et b loeffler
yade a nié tout et bâtons sont à moi qui
est très positif
bravo ici qu'ils envoient en effet par
ella ella votre prêtait spécificité
laisser leur inertie
d'autant que pas fait une convocation du
grand gars qu'à haïti va vite tout
casser dans sap autistes mon petit lien
bien aimé grands lacs à vous vouliez me
voir oui mieux et titus et je veux
savoir ce que tu as fidéle à petit ce
que je t'ai donné l'importance les
partys alors oui la potée la folie du
oui alors j'espère que tu ne l'as pas
cathy come on ou non grata voulait
toujours
après bien de mon mari c'est parfait
alors où est elle cette hypothèse et
balaie le temps 100 places le13 pas je
vous prie bryn ceci cela aller chercher
la position de la russie qui fuit quand
on prend pas et bérénice qui est dans la
peau tiff
j'étais là titus est trop longue et la
police tous ces lois elle est fragile ne
t'inquiète pas et seront ils fiables
regarde mes belles fleurs tu vois je
vais les mettre dans la peau douce avec
beaucoup d'eau et ce superbe et
abominable aux fleurs bleu rémy va d'un
noyé au vent de la peau qui vivent à la
limite tant pis s'il adore mes fleurs
comme un cétacé famille ici beaucoup
d'eau c'est très bien je suis bien
content c'est moi qui vais mettre les
fleurs je suis une artiste moi je suis
le plus pauvre en ait baissé mais les
belles fleurs regarde titus mots mais il
est mort sept et parents craignent à
cacher des preuves physician pente et
phan huy où me qui lisse et six blessés
titus mosca donc je peux toi de lui
accompagné le défunt il soigne levier
offrant titus crédible et proment pauvre
obélix important noyé dans cette pop et
imap aux travaux
[Musique]
tu es malade
pardonne moi je te dise au cuir je ne
suis pas allé dans ma potiche titus tu
vas mieux s'en sont les fleurs les
fleurs du grand yaka
elles m'ont fait tourner de l'oeil et
après après c'est une autre histoire